what better way to start in the morning
of the last day
can you hear me can you hear me
excellent cool all right so good morning
everyone
um so I guess in this room everyone
wants cryptography to exist but for all
we know it could just be impossible
um so in this in this talk I'm going to
talk a little bit about trying to find a
physical justification for the existence
of cryptography so there's going to be
computer science it's going to be a
little bit of physics a little bit of
philosophy it's going to be something
for everyone to find disagreeable or
agreeable
um I'll do my best uh so let's start a
little bit of a higher level about this
idea of trying to justify cryptography
uh using physical phenomena and let's
think about this notion of one-way
functions so these are functions that
are easy to compute but hard to invert
um and let's think for a minute what we
mean when we say that something is easy
or hard so we have this model
of uh polonomial time computation
but really the this notion of complexity
is supposed to capture the amount of
physical resources that are needed in
order to perform a computational task so
when we say something is hard we
actually want to model a situation where
you need to invest a lot of physical
resources in order to perform this task
so
um why do we think that these objects
one-way functions exist
so one reason is that there are some
mathematical problems that people tried
really hard to solve and couldn't solve
them and then we present uh this a
candidate for the one-way function which
is related to the hardness of solving
this hard problem for example factoring
but of course always in the back of our
minds uh there's a possibility that
we're just being silly and there is a
way to actually solve this problem using
little physical resources
um so we have to sort of make an
assumption
another approach is to sort of try to
witness nature around us and see that
there are some processes that seem to be
um unidirectional for example scrambling
egg seems to be an easy thing to do but
unscrambling seems to be pretty hard uh
so we can just sort of take that as some
evidence that one way-ness should exist
but again maybe there is some silliness
here because maybe there is a way to
sort of efficiently unscramble an egg
and we just haven't figured it out
he talks over
um so but but luckily so one one uh way
to go is to just trust if that there
isn't uh but actually there is like a
pretty good heuristic method uh for
trying to handle these sort of claims
and this is called science right so we
we don't just sort of make assumptions
based on what we see but rather sort of
conduct experiments and make
observations and based on that try to
come up with a model of sort of how the
universe behaves and we call this the
laws of nature and then if we do this
maybe we can sort of derive from the
laws of nature some reason why
unscrambling is hard for example I don't
know the second law of Thermodynamics or
something like that
um so this is sort of another way to try
to justify uh the existence of things
like one-way functions but of course we
need to be careful because this is not
going to be a proof uh that cryptography
or one-way functions exist so first of
all like these laws of nature are just a
conjecture maybe we're just being silly
and thinking that the second law of
Thermodynamics actually works maybe our
translation from uh sort of this our
model of complexity to actual natural
resources is wrong so you can sort of
try to think that maybe it's possible to
prove uh that in a classical World
factoring it's hard but maybe in a world
where scalable Quantum computation is
possible then factoring is easy so uh
just having a proof that factoring is
hard in a classical world is not going
to be uh sort of what we want
nevertheless this is sort of a different
angle to approach a problem so so it's
nice to get some independent evidence uh
from sort of the way that we're used to
thinking about it uh that cryptography
actually exists
might suppose that you know scrambling
an egg or breaking a glass is not
reversible it's really it's really one
way in a useful sense right so this is a
different question right where you can
derive an actual it's true right I mean
there's another step here that I'm not
even talking about but how do you
actually get like how do you model how
do you make a mathematical a
mathematical model that actually gives
you the properties of a1b function
distribution so and so forth based on
this physical process so I'm not getting
into that here at all uh however in the
phenomena that I am going to talk about
this is going to come out fairly
naturally so
um this is actually something nice to
keep in mind that it didn't have to be
like that
so the example so what I want to talk
about today is the connection between
Quantum cryptography and a phenomenon in
quantum gravity uh black hole radiation
um so let's start by introducing you to
a black hole uh so if you want a more
realistic photo
I have one here uh so this is the black
hole at the center of our galaxy so this
was taken by this event horizon
telescope and actually you don't see the
black hole because it's black so this is
the black no the black hole is in the
middle and what you see is sort of like
uh matter that's sort of circling around
the black hole and sort of um um falling
into it uh but the black holes that we
are going to think about don't have
stuff around them so we're just thinking
about like a black hole that exists in
empty space
uh and what do we need to know about the
about black holes
um so in the center of a black hole
there's this thing called a singularity
uh and Singularity has very uh very
extreme and very concentrated gravity
and it's not known how to do physics
when gravity is is very extreme and very
concentrated so this is sort of why
physicists are trying to work out the
theory of quantum gravity but for now we
don't know how to do sort of good
physics uh in the in the area of the
singularity so we don't really know how
what happens there
um the other interesting reason for our
talk is going to be sort of the boundary
of the black hole this is this event
horizon and this is this imaginary line
where if you cross it then you're going
to end up in the singularity sooner or
later now the Event Horizon at least for
uh big black holes is not an area of a
particularly extreme or concentrated
gravity so it should just look like
normal space like space that we know uh
and unlike uh areas like the singularity
uh physicists have really good theories
or on sort of what happens in uh regular
empty space like they know it really
would like you're not going to imagine
how well they know what happens in
ordinary space
um so there's there's this Quantum field
theory that that allows to make very
very accurate predictions
even when there's a little bit of
gravity like on Earth if you have if you
create a vacuum then they know pretty
well what's going on
um and when you try to apply these tools
to the region of the Event Horizon
do you realize that there's going to be
radiation that's going to be emitted
from the black hole so uh this is called
Hawking radiation and it was I think a
pretty big surprise when it was
discovered in the 70s I think uh for our
purposes we can just think about it as
um sort of information that's uh being
emitted uh from from the black hole
um so I'm just thinking about this
qubits that are sort of being thrown out
of the black hole um one at a time well
it's energy it contains energy it's a
wave function uh so it has energy yeah
it also has energy
um so what's going to happen if you take
a black hole uh and just sort of Leave
it to be it's going to start evaporating
so it's going to start emitting
radiation and the radiation is sort of
going to accumulate and the black hole
in the end is going to completely
evaporate so it's not clear what happens
the sort of close to the point where it
actually evaporates or it sort of gets
close to like a singularity but
um
I think the they are pretty confident
that uh sort of so long as black hole is
sufficiently large then the model for
this radiation should should be correct
um
that it's what contradictory one of the
things that are contradicting right
so the black hole becomes smaller and
smaller
okay
so the amount so that the size of the
black hole is is determined by its by
its mass so if you're emitting Mass to
be outside then you're going to shrink
Horizon actually for if you're an
outside Observer then you don't like as
far as you know only the Event Horizon
exists
um this is uh some sort of a lot there's
some holography thing going on there and
this variation is like a particle which
breaks into two parts one Falls
right so okay I'm non-expert on this so
this is a very common analogy I don't
know if it's completely accurate it's
not exactly particles it's these modes
which are like a superposition of
particles uh but you know this is where
I'm putting my hands up uh
um
oh okay uh so so this is uh this is what
happens
um and another thing that we know is
that well okay so this is related to
what people were saying uh that about
it's good to think about this
information like the information is
emitted is sort of maximally entangled
with other information that remains
inside the black hole and this is
because sort of vacuum if you think
about sort of empty space in Quantum
field Theory it's very spatially
entangled like if you think think about
an area which is local then all of the
the quantum fields in this area are
going to be very entangled with each
other so if something pops out then
something else needs that is entangled
needs to needs to go inside it's not
electromagnetic radiation
the electromagnetic radiation uh but it
could be other types of particles
it's everything yeah it's supposed to be
everything
um
okay uh it looks like we in the next
Workshop we need to have a physics talk
as well
um
okay yeah so again for our purposes if
you're thinking about uh information
Theory then and I'm saying that the
outgoing radiation I'm just thinking
about the black hole is you know
throwing out um qubits then for every
qubits that you toss out there's a QB
that remains inside and these qubits are
let's say in an epr state so zero zero
plus one one over square root two so I'm
going to use this drock notation uh
throughout the talk I hope it's not too
intimidating
um
okay so uh this is sort of what happens
and now let's try to think at the level
of the universe what happens so we can
divide the universe into three parts
um
one is sort of the area that's sort of
outside the black hole so this is the
contains the radiation for the path so
we're going to call it R one is the sort
of qubit that's being popped at this
current at the current time I'm going to
call it B uh and there's also the
interior of the black hole that we
denote by H uh and um hbr is sort of the
entire universe and uh because the
entire universe it's going to be a pure
state so at the level of the entire
universe there's no such thing as
measurement only unitary Evolution so
you can just think about the universe
starting at sort of state zero and
evolving according to a known unitary so
supposedly we can know the laws of
physics so we know how things evolve
um and then a black hole gets yeah a
black hole is created and because we're
dealing with an example where there's
nothing else acceptable like call it's
just going to start radiating
um and again physicists know
um of properties that this radiation is
supposed to have but the interesting
point comes when you pass the halfway
point of the life of the black hole this
is called the page time and after page
time something annoying happens so if
you look at the if you look at a qubit
that is uh emitted after the page time
then it's supposed to have two
properties one is that it's supposed to
be maximally entangled so it's supposed
to be in an epr pair with this inside
modes so this is what Quantum field
Theory tells us that there's supposed to
be an inside mode that is
um maximally entangled with the outgoing
radiation but from entropy
considerations
you also can derive that this outgoing
radiation needs to be
um almost maximally entangled with the
radiation from the task so I'm currently
not formalizing what it means to be
maximally entangled with like sort of a
big state but we're going to get to it
in a couple of slides but the point is
that but this is this is a problem
because uh in Quantum information we
know that
um a system cannot be maximally
entangled with two different systems so
something something needs to be
explained here
and there's a really nice explanation uh
that has to do with complementarity so
for instance we're saying well look if
this B is maximally entangled with
something here in something in h and
also with something in R then actually
maybe H and R are really the same system
maybe it's like sort of the same Gilbert
space that manifests itself manifests
itself in two different ways outside and
inside and like if you're outside then
you're going to see what's going on
outside and if you're inside then you're
inside and you cannot sort of see what's
what's hap what happens what's happening
outside so maybe maybe it's okay maybe
it's it's not really a problem
um and I think a lot of people think
that this is uh the way to go
um but then in in 2013
um there was this uh introduction of
this uh firewall Paradox it's not
actually a paradox it's just a thought
experiment
um that shows that maybe things are more
complicated uh than uh um they thought
before so let's talk about this uh
firewall experiment
so again this is this is sort of a
thought experiment and and the goal is
to try to sort of expose this violation
of the monogamy of entanglement
um uh in these two systems
so we have Alice Alice is the player and
it sits outside of the black hole and
Alice knows all of the laws of nature so
so she knows what is the unitary
evolution of the black hole and so on
and notice that we think that the
Universe Works efficiently so everything
for example the evolution of the of the
black hole is what we would call uh sort
of polynomial time process so she can
for example simulate the black hole on
her computer if she wants
um so Alice is outside the Black Hole uh
and she captures the sort of the
radiation from the past so she sits
there from the beginning of time and she
just collects this information
um and then Alice is going to distill
the entanglement now I'm going to go
back to this um what does it mean for B
to be maximally entangled with r it
means there exists information
theoretically a process that takes R and
produces a qubit d such that B and D are
an epr here again like zero zero plus
one one so you know if you just look at
R by itself then maybe you don't see it
immediately but there is a way to
process uh there exists a way to process
R uh so as to obtain sort of the uh
entanglement entanglement partner
um of uh of of the qubit
so Alice just sort of finds this D
and then she collects this new outgoing
qbb and checks that indeed BD uh have
have entanglements so that we have the
right uh um PPR pair and then she's
going to jump into the black hole uh to
look for the other epr partner uh and
and sort of violate witness the
violation of the monogamy of
entanglement so
um for complementarity you you hope that
R and H are completely separate so this
shows that you can somehow sort of bring
them together
um in a way that's that's problematic
and the conclusion is that
um sort of these these entangled modes
um shouldn't be able to exist so really
The Event Horizon does not behave like
normal empty space
um like you'd think but rather there's
some high energy barrier that breaks the
attack so if there's uh um in order to
be able to make empty space not
entangled with each other you need a
high energy barrier and this is uh um
illustrated by this firewall
um
and uh this is sort of the conclusion uh
that they had there that these firewalls
should exist
um and this is I think to some people
undesirable because uh it seems like we
should be able like to think about the
event horizon area just as normal empty
space and applying normal physics there
um so this is why it's a paradox even
though it could be the case that really
somehow I don't know the singularity
affects the area of the Event Horizon
and creates and creates a firewall
um but there's something to uh just a
second there is some intuition that it
shouldn't have
referral you mean that no information
can go in or just that like the the area
here in the area here are unentangled oh
there's unentangled yeah
um yeah in order for space to be empty
uh it needs to be like very highly in
Quantum field here as far as I know like
everything that I say that has to do
with physics is like has a disclaimer on
it so sorry so you say that they cannot
be entangled how does that relate to us
being able to jump into the black hole
she can but there's not going to be any
sort of partner here
the radiation there's not going to be in
these entangled modes we want to prevent
them from from
um existing so it's basically in the
previous slide which says
the inside age right they're saying that
they couldn't yeah they're saying that
there's a reason to believe that it
shouldn't happen uh and here's a way to
prevent it by having this uh by having
this file
um
so you know maybe these firewalls just
exist uh but uh
um I think some people in the physical
Community are very highly motivated to
find a way out uh to sort of make
physics work uh in normal conditions so
like you think about Event Horizon as
like space that we know how to analyze
and and sort of make it so that this is
still the case and what the Harlan
Hayden suggested is what if this
distillation process going from R to D
is computationally hard it's
computationally intractable this means
that it's going to take Alice a lot of
time to actually go from R to D and in
that time Nintendo modes are going to
already reach the singularity or the
black hole is already going to evaporate
and you're not going to be able to
conduct this experiment
um so and and they show some evidence uh
that indeed this um distillation
procedure could be that there could be a
case there could be a setting where such
distillation would be an intractable
task based on computational
considerations so that that's kind of
cool things incorporating computer
science into the problem
um so this is pretty weird when you
think about it right like okay so this
is going to be computationally hard and
therefore like you're somehow forcing
Alice's hand to not be able to see uh uh
to not be able to see this uh violation
of monogamy and somehow this is fine
um but I think that maybe it's okay
maybe this is fine uh so you could say
well this can be completely intractable
but maybe I'm just going to um I know
spend a lot of time or a lot of energy
and just run it in parallel for using
exponential amount of resources and then
I'm going to be able to do it
um but the whole point is that we know
that under extreme conditions like new
things happen like we don't know how to
analyze things where there is like
extreme extremely high gravity or
extremely high energy so maybe in order
to uh be able to sort of efficiently in
order to solve this computational
problem in time you need to I know
create a black hole or do something like
this where you know you need some other
Theory So you you're sort of kicking the
can down the line and and sort of saying
in normal conditions we think that the
world should make sense
I'm not part of
part of the universe you can think about
them as actually being a part of the
universe so I mean you can think about
this R is starting from like it has like
a very long uh sort of sequence of zeros
and Alice it's there
[Music]
so so you're saying by the time Alice
distills uh
yeah it comes into the singularity and
then we don't need to handle it this is
like you know quantum gravity please
take over
um but there's also this other issue
right that inside the black hole time
sort of stops so from Alice's
perspective the particle actually never
falls into it Singularity right so
actually so if Alice jumps inside then
actually it does uh if you stay if you
stay outside and again actually I'm not
sure what happens if you have like an
entangle mode that he's created at the
Event Horizon but it is true that for an
outside Observer you never see anything
that is that falls actually inside
you're going to see it getting very
close and closer to the event horizon
but it never Falls inside and this is
sort of the reason why I said that you
can actually think if you're just
staying outside and you can just think
of what the black hole is only happening
at the area of the Event Horizon and you
don't think need to think about the
black for having an interior like at all
but if you but you can go inside and
then it doesn't interior
so computationally hard that here
there's no like asymptotics or anything
just like a concrete amount of physical
time that it takes to like it could be
right so could it not be like very much
space related to the complexity of like
for example the entangle modes uh
getting into the singularity or the
evaporation of the black hole so you're
actually comparing uh sort of two uh two
processes one is an installation time
and the other is the time that it takes
nature to sort of cover up for this uh
for this uh violation of is it clear the
second time is long not like why why is
it a milliseconds so it's not clear but
but Harlow Hayden actually sort of
explain why uh uh they think so okay I
don't wanna I I don't remember the
numbers so
it has to do again with with like the
mass of the black hole so it's some
polynomial like maybe enter the 1.5 or
something like this that it takes the
black hole to evaporate so so long as
it's n is the mass of the black hole
so yeah there's gonna be some security
parameter yeah but look if where the if
the black hole is too small then again
we don't know how to say anything so
this is like it's very easy to Escape
right whenever Things become tractable
then we know that we can't solve so so I
mean like whenever Things become small
then we know that we don't have the
right Theory so actually just do this
thought experiment Alice has to jump
into the back right she needs to jump
inside oh it's too small you cannot even
jump into it
so when Alice jumps into the platform
my competition
right so actually this is not I didn't
see this treated in the literature at
all so
I think they I think they think that
it's not that it shouldn't be a problem
but I don't know
what what was the question uh so how
hard is maybe it's maybe it's hard to
actually find the entangled partner and
uh uh maybe the hard part is not
distilling the uh distilling the the
rather fighting the partnership
everybody's body is right everybody
there that's the point of the black hole
though you know you know whatever yeah
so long as you're you can observe it
then it's going to be bad enough right
so but the the the pair is going to
slightly fall into the similarity right
yeah but you're you're in that region
where things grew very slowly right no
but if Alice oh you're saying that oh I
see you're saying it's going to actually
take it out what could be the distilling
uh
for that particular activity which is
sitting right up okay so so ubis was
saying for the mic that uh
things that the Horizon moved very
slowly from the frame of reference of
the outside so it shouldn't be that hard
to sort of keep track of where this uh
um where this radiation came from and
look for the partner in that area
okay
right so
it's true and and you can try to say but
so the question is what you want what do
you want physical Theory to describe
right you want to be you want to you
want to have a theory such that you know
any Observer should be able to sort of
look at the laws of nature and predict
what's going to happen to it including
an observer that sort of falls into it
so you want quantum theory to also be
correct even if you're like one of these
adventurous people that falls into the
black or you shouldn't see something
that's non-physical even if you're
you're not allowed to tell anyone
I always talk to other people who fell
into the black hole
also you know also the topic what
happens if that breaks but okay
[Music]
um
so let's let's be a little bit more
concrete about this I have no idea how
much time I have uh not a lot okay uh
about this problem of the black hole
radiation decoding or Harlow heightened
decoding you can call it
um so the setup for this problem is uh
sort of the evolution of the universe so
there is some way where this uh sort of
State over these three subsystems HB and
R uh gets gets generated and again we
think of b as a single qubit
um and we have a promise that b and R
are entangled so there exists a possibly
inefficient procedure to start from R
and uh derive
um a qbd such that BD are an epr pair
now the input to the problem is X is you
get access to the register R and your
goal is to come up with register D such
that B and D are correlated so
um you can you can think about uh trying
to come up with with these such as B and
B are perfectly entangled but uh in
order to witness the violation of
entanglement it's sufficient for them to
be even somewhat correlated because the
epr partner of B is going to be fully
correlated with it
um so it shouldn't be correlated at all
with any other uh um
with any with any other subsystem
that's inside is somehow the real one
and therefore this one is bad I mean why
not the other way around like maybe the
one outside the real partner and inside
is not
so
I I think so you're saying maybe it can
be like highly correlated with this one
and only slightly correlated with that
so
I I think
um that uh the reason is that you you
just really believe uh Quantum field
Theory and it suggests that these that
these Partners should be really really
highly entangled this is my answer but
again like all physics question I have
to physics is saying that that should be
the case I think so that's the best
answer that I can get
um
so what was during the prior work uh so
they were considering uh sort of just
just trying to show that uh something
useful can be said about this so so uh
they were considering the case of sort
of perfect perfectly recovering uh the
uh the registered date and they showed
that this is hard under computational
assumptions
um so in Harlow Hayden they assumed um
that uh SDK is not bqp uh so so some
problems in statistical zero knowledge
are actually hard for for Quantum
polynomial time uh and they get some
sort of a worst case hardness so so
somehow
um um for you know for every adversary
there exists a black hole that it should
not be able to decode if we try to
interpret it
um Aaronson uh gave an argument that
uses injective one of the functions
um and uh so the claim there was was
average case but based on sort of more
cryptographic assumption based on
average case assumption
uh and
um what we do here is sort of again
study this thing uh yeah just going back
so HH said it said that if let's say
factoring is hard so then this recovery
is hard
so if uh there exists an SDK complete
problem that is not in bqp
uh
uh oh it doesn't have to be complete but
if there is a non-complete one there's
also a complete one
right
it is
okay so it's not uh I mean but if yeah I
mean if factoring is in bqp anything
else in particular yeah
yeah um
sorry the model is a little bit confused
because
you're making computational assumptions
so presumably Alice could be a
computationally unbounded right so far
what you have said does not so uh so we
are assuming that at least is
computationally bounded if if Alice can
use unbounded resources then again we
don't know what happens right if Alice
can have like a exponential a lot of
energy and sort of concentrate it on her
computer then I don't know maybe she
creates a black hole or something else
that we don't know how to analyze life
so the point here is to think what
happens in normal condition like the
universe needs to make sense under
normal conditions this is how I think
about it universe is compositionally
refusable
I mean it could be the case that you can
concentrate a lot of energy in a small
point but then we don't know what
happens to get some better high level I
should think of this work is like using
complexity Theory to justify that the
physics is okay that like this problem
so I think they justify that the physics
could be okay right like
I don't know that there is a model that
says that uh it has to be the case that
black holes should be created in this
way but you can sort of try to go in the
opposite direction and say well
if we think that nature should make
sense then black hole should be created
levels should be created to have this
property and this shows that it is
actually possible okay uh and and this
actually sort of ties to the next point
where we might not just want to be able
to show that under some computational
assumptions uh this problem is hard but
rather if this problem is hard and if we
say well this problem needs to be hard
for like you know some sort of physical
intuition then this implies that some
computational problem is hard which is
good for us
um so in this work uh so we give the
quantitative definition of this uh of
this problem
um where so in previous work it was just
defined in a more high level uh way
without uh without all the parameters
um and we give an existential
equivalence between the hardness of this
black hole radiation decoding problem
and this arguably minimal uh Quantum
cryptographic objects
uh so
um this goes in both directions so on
one hand we show that you don't even
need to have one-way functions in order
to have like uh hard problems uh for for
this radiation part instances of this
radiation decoding and on the other hand
if radiation decoding is indeed hard
then you get some notion of quantum
cryptography you don't necessarily get
one-way functions but you get this
notion uh that we call uh that's called
EFI or non-interactive statistically
binding commitments
um
so yeah so so this this uh uh these bhrd
hard States exist if and only if
um this uh EFI slash non-directed
specifically binding commitment uh
Quantum commitments uh exist
so just to say what this if I'm not sure
they'll even get to it but let me just
say what it is we're going to hear about
it more uh from from Iran later
um so EFI just means that there are two
distributions over Quantum States uh
that are um computationally
indistinguishable but are statistically
far and
um you can actually show that the
existence of these things uh is
equivalent to a bunch of quantum
cryptography Primitives
um again the one that I'm going to care
about here is commitment uh but there's
there's also other things commitments
oblivious transfer
um and more uh so really
um again so this puts this uh sort of
beach or the problem at least in this
formalism together with with this uh
sort of collection of other
cryptographic tasks question
so uh this is the EF file what was known
about it before I mean you are yes
and we just connected to the black hole
black hole stuff
so that tells you know applications like
if EFI can be used to do all this but in
terms of existence like you're
connecting it with the bhrt so all these
are sorry all these are existential
equivalents so it's not just that you
can use EF5 to construct these you can
use them to get a different I think he's
asking
this is
okay uh so
um they're weaker than what we found so
if one Reflections exist then of course
uh then if I exist because you can even
get classical distributions that are
statistically far on computationally
distinguishable
um
I think there's going to be talks about
this so I mean anyone can it's anybody's
guess but I think most people there are
some separations that show that uh um
things like EFI and even stronger
objects could exist even if only
functions do not exist so there are sort
of uh relativevised ways relativized
reasons
not that I know oh my God
Okay so
oh we'll see we'll see how far we should
um okay so let's go back to the
definition I'll try to show you how how
the connections work uh in either
direction
so I just want to say that we can think
sort of again there's a reason there's a
uh you get a parameter of saying how
correlated you want uh you want your
adversary to uh um to be with with uh
um with the radiation BP so you can
think about sort of an easy variant
which is just to try to find any
non-trivial correlation
uh if you think about the hardware
variant where you want to really uh come
up with
um a near epr correlation between d and
d uh and again you can say uh uh what's
the probability of success so you want
to be able to succeed with with
non-negligible probability
um and this is sort of uh
so the harder case where which would we
should still be able to violate uh um
um this uh uh firewall
um scenario so we might want to be able
to uh sort of
um prevent this as well
right so I was asked before it I think
it should be something like the size of
the black hole like the the mass of the
black hole when you translate it into
using your language like if there were
multiple Majors
you are using the same algorithm across
all how much more effort you interpreter
is that the asymptotics right so there
is a there is a question here about like
how to uh deal with asymptotics and
maybe and is it right do you really is
this really like polonial versus super
polonomial time really the right
separation that you want between what is
going to be sufficiently intractable in
order to prevent this uh the physical
question
I'm not getting into that now so it was
uh uh discussed a little bit in in the
horrible hiding paper and I'm mentioning
like mentioning the mentioned it in
passing also in in this paper but uh
it's true that you can investigate a lot
more in the parameters of this problem
um so what we show is that
um you know even if only the heart
variant is hard then you get uh then you
get EFI and if you have EFI then even
the easy variant is easy and notice that
this is an existential equivalent so it
doesn't mean that it's the same system
like that if a certain sort of black
hole is is uh sort of hard for the hard
variant then it's also hard for the easy
variant but rather if there exists a
black hole for which the hard variant is
hard then you can also think about a
black hole where even the easy variant
is hard
um so this is uh this is what we get
um so let's see let's try to see the
construction uh so we I have like six
minutes
which direction do you want to see
they're more interesting favorite
so I'm just going to say so okay so this
direction uses
um uses commitment so essentially what
would happen is that we're going to
generate an epr pair and just uh sort of
commit to uh in in the in the r region
we're just going to give a commitment to
the sort of the half of the epr pair so
we we start with an epr pair and commit
to this part and this is sort of
inspired by what happened in Harlow
Hayden also in erinson you can think
about what happens there as some sort of
commitment but when you try to do it uh
carefully you see that you will need to
be careful in particular if you want to
really be able to show that even the
easy version is hard uh then you need to
really sort of show that uh you can use
the commitment in such a way well that
first of all it is uh
um information theoretically possible to
recover uh to actually recover the qubit
from from r
and also that it's uh that you can use
the commitments in order to completely
hide what's going on so actually what
you should what we get this what we can
show is that if commitments exists then
R and B are computationally
indistinguishable from being in terms of
product so even though they're very
highly entangled
um to any efficient uh distinguisher
they're going to look
um it seem to be intensive product and
without further Ado I'm going to move to
the other uh to the other direction so
we want to create I want to create an
EFI so we want to create two
indistinguishable distributions
um and what we do there is actually sort
of even though this bhrd is like a
Quantum search problem right you get a
quantum input and you need to come up
with uh your output is a qubit which has
some some properties
um we show that you can actually find a
classical hardcore bit uh for this uh
given this problem
um and in particular the construction of
the EFI is going to be the following so
you start with like you generate this
hard to decode stage where you we know
we start with the assumption that this
problem is hard and then you apply the
so-called Quantum one-time pad which I
was supposed to explain the previous
slides if you don't know what it is it's
just a one-time Pad but for quantum
qubits
and then your Epi pair is either going
to be like the B and R together with the
quantum with the actual Quantum one time
pedal you use orb and R together with
like two random bits that are completely
independent of the of the One Time Pad
um and what we can show is that uh um so
we we call this problem like uh the
super density coding problem because
it's related to this uh notion of uh
super dense coding that you can do with
epr pair so you know if you have an epr
pair then uh and and you know if we have
two two parties and each one has one of
the qubits of an epr pair then I can
send two classical bits along the
communication Channel by just sending
one qubit and essentially the way that
I'm doing it is by thinking about the
two classical bits that I want to encode
is a key for a Quantum One Time Pad I
use it to encrypt I encrypt my half of
the epr with this one to one time Tab
and send it over and uh the point is
that if you have the other part of the
uh the other half of the APR pair then
you can actually recover uh the um uh
the key for my uh for my one-time pad
and this is sort of how the
communication Channel Works
um so this is sort of what this problem
is is sort of aiming it and what we're
showing is that uh
um this uh uh so this super dense coding
is actually also also it's essentially
the same operation uh that you perform
when you're teleporting uh when you're
doing quantum teleportation of a qubit
so actually what we're showing is that
if an adversary manages to sort of solve
this super density coding problem that
we can actually cheat so instead of
giving giving it the correct B we're
giving it a half of an epr pair where we
have the other half
and what the adversary actually does it
implicitly teleports the
um the cubic D into our uh into our
register so it thinks that it's doing a
decoding but actually it's doing a
teleportation so these two things are
actually the same operation
um and this is sort of how we get a
reduction from uh sort of solving the
super dense decoding problem to actually
finding D so this question in the
interest sure yeah so I'm just going to
uh sort of wrap up so this is uh this is
going to give you
um in EFI construction based on the
heart on the
easy version of the problem the hardness
of the easy version if you want to rely
on the hardness of the hard version then
you need to do some amplification uh
there are some questions here I should
also mention uh that uh Luen told me
blue and showed me like a different uh
way to show this to show this reduction
sort of doing a dual construction so
instead of looking at B and R you're
actually thinking about H as some sort
of commitment so there's another at
least one other nice way of of sort of
getting the result it seems right is
there a proof
um so let me wrap up uh so it seems like
like hard problems come up in nature
um and if they're essential then
um it's a good evidence that
cryptography could exist
um
so Harlan how you doing uh um we're
using computational hardness to try to
sort of censor the violation of monogamy
of entanglement
and
um what we show is that in some way
again so like I don't want to over hype
it so there's there's a lot of
disclaimers but in some sense uh you can
see this you can
see the if you believe that this
violation of monogamy should be censored
then maybe you should believe that
Quantum cryptography exists
uh and you could think about about other
places where you can try to find
phenomena uh which which have similar
properties uh in particular so this this
area of quantum gravity seems to be very
heavy in uh uh sort of quantum very
related to Quantum information and maybe
computational tasks so this could be
like a good area to uh sort of try to
find interesting connections thank you
however it is it to verify
so essentially you just you could just
measure in this epr basis so if you just
want to oh sorry don't so if I guess if
I guess something right you need to be
able to do it better than
so if
it's even probably one fourth and
essentially you can show that anything
better than that is going to give you
some laundry approach
this problem is hard because the
distribution the same as what do you
expect receiving actually I don't think
so
but but it could be the case that a
black hole Creator I mean it seems like
it has to be a commitment of some sort
so uh I I and also you know we just
assuming a PFI exists right if I can
come can have many different shapes so
so uh if you pick a specific one like
maybe one that's implied by the one-way
function that comes from lwe then maybe
it's not what you would expect from a
natural process but I yeah I don't know
um
entropy distributions maybe we can get
random States also from right so there's
there's I think that there are questions
about the relation between sort of
random Quantum objects like random
States and and random unitaries to black
holes uh usually the Dynamics of black
holes are modeled by a random unitary uh
which again this is uh sort of
contradicts the fact that you want to be
you wanted to be an efficient process
but this seems to be good enough for for
some purposes so a lot of things that
that can be sort of investigated uh in
this in this area so I have a question
so do you expect to see if you want to
think about like getting more results in
this area are you thinking of getting
using uh Quantum phenomena is to try to
prove other things like more more okay
stronger cryptographic assumptions yeah
you could so there's this
um blog post by Scott Aronson where he
describes a conversation that he had
with uh influence and
actual bit so this is recorded time you
should give credit
um and there he sort of suggests that
maybe there's this
um there's this physical Duality it's
called absc FD it's it's very hyped
between things that happen on the
boundary of some types of universes and
what happens inside and sometimes God
suggested maybe this is sometimes this
could be some type of homomorphic
encryption so there's this work of uh
Umesh and others that show that uh um
actually the translation between the
boundary and the ball and the inside
should be computationally hard so maybe
you can think about this like as an
encrypted version like the the the uh
the outside the encrypted version of
what's of what's in the inside and if
you sort of do uh uh sort of Natural
Evolution on the outside then actually
you're doing some sort of homomorphic
operational data this is the craziest
example that I apparently have but who
knows
of extensions
that you know if really is the case that
uh
computational hardness is ingrained is a
physical of nature uh that you know some
people shortcut or something but maybe
there's evidence with outside battles
maybe there is a very evidence here
right right yeah so this is why do we do
so I think what I said go to black holes
but maybe you can just I don't know uh
doing uh what do you call it uh
can any of this evidence say something
about classical cryptography like
it's really a good question there's a
really good question like we don't I
don't know
um yeah interesting
interesting so there's a question of
what is the classical complexity of
solving this radiation like what kind of
Oracle uh what kind of Oracle do you
need
what kind of Oracle do you need in order
to so this is like my cheat
do you need in order to what kind of
classical Oracle do you need in order to
solve this decoding problem and this is
an open question uh so maybe yeah
[Applause]
yeah
foreign